Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's ein sehr spezielles Video.
Und zwar hat mir eine Followerin über Instagram über die Privatnachrichten
diesen Rezeptvorschlag geben.
Und ich dachte erstmal so: "Hmm...ist das wirklich ein Rezept?"
Weil es hat einfach nur so 2 Zutaten, und zwar Pudding und Kekse!
Aber rausgekommen ist was so Cooles und dann hab ich mir gedacht ich mach das nach.
Ich weiß leider deinen Namen nicht mehr, also wenn du das siehst:
Danke für die Inspiration!
Und ich hab jetzt keinen Schokopudding da,
deswegen machen wir den heute selber.
Aber es sind im Endeffekt einfach wirklich nur zwei Zutaten: Pudding und Kekse.
Und raus kommt ein gestreifter Pudding-Keks Kuchen!
Also bleibt auf jeden Fall bis zum Ende dran!
Für den Schokopudding benötigen wir Milch, Backkakao,
Speisestärke und Zucker.
Und außerdem Kekse, hier benötigen wir einmal Kakaokekse
und normale Butterkekse.
Also bevor es jetzt zu Missverständnissen kommt: mit Fertigpudding meine ich diesen
Fertig-Schokopudding aus der Tüte, den hab ich garnicht da.
Aber es ist eine gute Gelegenheit, um euch zu zeigen, wie der ganz schnell selber geht
Und zwar nehme ich jetzt hier die Milch, gebe die Hälfte davon in meinen Topf,
schalte den Topf aber noch nicht ein.
Ich nehm mir jetzt die drei anderen Zutaten, also Zucker, Backkako und Speisestärke
und verrühre das mit der restlichen Milch klümpchenfrei
und dann machen wir erst den Herd an.
Und weil der Backkakao sehr trocken ist - der ist ja stark entölt,
also nehmt da nicht den Trinkkakao - ist es ein bisschen schwierig,
das klümpchenfrei zu rühren, geht dann aber dann nach ungefähr 1 ½ Minuten.
Und jetzt hab ich den Herd eingeschaltet und sobald ihr merkt,
dass die Milch hochsteigen will, gebt ihr die Kakaomasse dazu
und rührt einfach ständig um, lasst das einmal aufkochen
und dann ist der Pudding fertig.
Und sobald die Bläschen aufsteigen, ist der Pudding fertig.
Der ist nämlich jetzt schön eingedickt durch die Speisestärke, Herd aus.
Und ihr könnt - ihr müsst aber nicht - ihr könnt das jetzt noch durch ein Sieb geben,
damit er komplett klümpchenfrei ist.
Ich mach das jetzt und dann geht's weiter.
So und das war's jetzt auch schon mit der Vorbereitung,
wir können direkt anfangen, zu schichten.
Der Pudding muss dabei noch warm bzw. heiß sein, also nicht abkühlen lassen!
Und jetzt nehm ich mir ein Tablett, wo ich das Ganze drauf servieren möchte,
außerdem noch meinen Tortenring, ihr könnt auch irgendwas anderes nehmen;
Gegenstände, die die Kekse einfach vorne und hinten festhalten, damit sie nicht umkippen.
Und jetzt nehmen wir uns immer einen dunklen Keks, bestreichen den mit unserem Pudding
und dann müssen wir das ganz einfach abwechselnd schichten.
Ihr könnt auch ein wenig Pudding auf den Boden streichen, das ist quasi unser "Kleber".
Hallo ich bin's, die Kiki aus der Zukunft!
Und zwar bin ich schon gerade ein paar Schritte weiter.
Mir ist ein kleiner Fehler unterlaufen, was aber absolut nicht tragisch ist.
Und zwar hab ich die Kekse hochkant reingelegt statt quer.
Macht den Fehler nicht!
Es ist wie gesagt nicht so tragisch, ihr könnt das im Nachhinein immernoch ändern
aber ich hab gedacht es ist ein bisschen korrekter, wenn ich euch das jetzt schon sage.
Und jetzt viel Spaß beim Video!
Also ich muss sagen dieses Schichten macht echt Spaß!
Und das ist auch so ein Rezept: jeder hat die Zutaten zuhause,
also man muss nicht noch extra los (H: Gerade die, die Kinder haben!)
Genau. Vor allem ich hab ja auch also meine Schwägerinnen,
die haben alle Kinder und dann ist das auch immer so
ja, jetzt Zeit für eine aufwendige Torte ist ja dann nicht,
mit 3 Kindern zum Beispiel aber das geht ja wirklich schnell
und da können die Kinder sogar mithelfen!
Ich bin jetzt komplett fertig mit dem Schichten,
ich lass jetzt auch den Tortenring dran für die Stabilisation.
Und jetzt brauchen wir aber noch ein bisschen von unserem Pudding, den hab ich mir übrig gelassen.
Ich hab übrigens ungefähr 40 Kekse verbraucht,
also 20 helle und 20 dunkle.
Und jetzt wird der Kuchen wenn man das so sagen darf, oder die Torte
noch mit Pudding eingestrichen.
Mir ist ein Fehler unterlaufen aber immer schön das Positive sehen:
Gott sei Dank ist das mir jetzt aufgefallen!
Denn das Ganze muss eher so flach liegen,
das heißt wir brauchen so ein bisschen mehr Breite.
Das heißt ich nehm jetzt ganz einfach den Tortenring ab
und dann stürze ich das und dann machen wir wie gehabt weiter!
Jetzt hab ich rundherum alles eingestrichen und jetzt nehm ich den Tortenring ab
und dann streiche ich noch die Seiten ein.
Sobald ihr dann zufrieden seid und alles schön glatt verstrichen habt,
(ich werd jetzt aber gleich auf jeden Fall noch das Serviertablett ein bisschen sauber machen)
gebt ihr das in den Kühlschrank, und zwar für 2h.
In der Zeit werden die Kekse schön weich, der Pudding härtet aus,
er wird kalt und dann zeige ich euch den coolen Anschnitt.
Also ich hab jetzt meinen Kuchen über Nacht abkühlen lassen.
Das könnt ihr natürlich auch, da wird auch nichts matschig,
das verspreche ich euch!
Am nächsten Tag solltet ihr es dann aber wirklich anschneiden.
Und wir schneiden das jetzt nicht gerade an,
weil sonst würde man ja das Muster nicht erkennen.
Ich hab hierfür so einen kleinen Trick, und zwar hab ich hier mein Messer
- am besten nehmt ihr so ein Messer mit Wellenschliff -
und dann hab ich das hier in heißes Wasser getunkt.
Einmal ganz kurz abtrocknen und dann können wir das rautenförmig anschneiden.
Also abschließend muss ich echt sagen:
ich bin begeistert von dem Rezept!
Die Kekse sind total weich geworden, das Ganze hat nicht lange gedauert
und ihr habt so eine coole Optik, da werden eure Gäste euch bestimmt fragen:
"Was hast du gemacht? Hast du gezaubert oder was ist das?".
Also ich möchte euch nochmal ganz kurz hier die Konsistenz zeigen, wie weich das ist
du kannst ruhig näher ran, schaut mal.
Also es ist schon ziemlich weich!
Und es schmeckt halt so, wie man sich das vorstellt: Kekse mit Pudding.
Ich genieß das jetzt aber noch mit Kaffee und dann freu ich mich,
wenn ihr beim nächsten Mal einschaltet.
Genau die Mengenangaben stehen immer unten in der Infobox,
die müsst ihr einfach aufklappen, dann könnt ihr das Ganze nachmachen.
Ich freu mich über eure Fotos mit dem Hashtag #kikiskitchen auf Instagram.
Und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten Mal auf kikiskitchen.
Tschüss!